Anita and Bill for more on this we're
joined Now by former acting ice director
and Fox News contributor Tom Holman Tom
you just heard Bill's great reporting
and mentioning that in just Del Rio's
sector already this fiscal year which is
essentially 30 days it's been 50 000
nearly in just El Rio border-wide I'm
told it's over 200 000. it seems that
things are not slowing down no the the
my sources said it's going to be about
210 000 border patrol pensions 30 to 50
000 ofo app branches which can be a
quarter million that's a quarter million
people in one month but the scariest
number is the 86 000 gotaways last month
86 000 people enter this country didn't
didn't turn themselves in to claim a
sign and be released they avoided
apprehension and there's a reason they
did that they don't want to be
fingerprinted what does that mean
they're gang members they're criminal
they're carrying fentanyl or Worse
they're an unsuspected terrorists I've
said this over and over again I don't
care what people's opinions illegal
immigration this is historical
immigration border patrol is arrested
people from 161 countries many of these
countries are sponsors of terrorism
86 000 people entered the country last
month and got away why that's just
scared the hell out of everybody I mean
I don't know how many terrorists cross
the border but if you don't think a
single one
of eighty six thousand came from a
country of sponsored terrorism then
they're ignoring the data it's just this
is the biggest National Security failure
since 9 11. and how big you talk about
people's opinions how important to this
midterm election Tom is the Border issue
is what you're talking about with the
National Security risk well I'm hoping
I'm hoping people look beyond the just
like again regardless what their
opinions on illegal immigration they
look Beyond this crisis is so big up to
80 percent of border patrol agents have
been pulled off the lines process what
does that mean that's when a fentanyl
comes across they killed over a hundred
thousand Americans that's when the
criminals in the MS-13 and and the gang
members come across and and I want to
keep focusing on the national security
issue in the last since Joe Biden's
taking office there's been over one
million galloways
one million people that didn't want to
turn themselves in that's a national
security issue and and last month 86
000. if you spread that out for the next
12 months that's one million gotaways in
one year this country can't sustain that
this is a huge National Security concern
so I hope the voters remember that when
they go to the polls next week if it is
a big issue enough in places like
Arizona for example in Tucson that Pima
County there votes heavily uh Democrat
but if enough crossovers weren't able to
put people in power like Blake Masters
like Kerry Lake in the governor's office
what do you hope the Republicans will do
well look we take them back to the house
in in the Senate the president President
Biden still has the power of the
executive pen but now we have the power
to purse so there's a couple things we
can do number one we can you know stop
the ridiculous legislation but you're
still going to do some executive action
but we can we can hold this
Administration accountable say look if
you don't do something if you don't take
steps to secure this border and the
secretary's gonna stop lying about a
secure border 86 000 escapees in one
month is not a secure border then shut
it down we have the power to purse and
people say well that's a drastic except
shutting the government down we got a
hundred thousand Americans debt we've
got 86 000 people across the border last
month that weren't arrested at what
point is enough enough we got over we
got over 1400 migrants if the
Republicans take the house which it
looks like at least that will happen and
or the Senate should they as we've heard
some calls try and draw up impeachment
papers on secretary mayorkas absolutely
on day one that man is has violated the
old office he's took he he lied to
American people he's committed perjury
in front of Congress when this says the
board is secure this country is less
safe under his leadership absolutely day
one he needs to be impeached day one Tom
Hillman former acting ice director and
fox contributor Tom thank you very much
three days to go I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis